all right let's jump right in today many
topics related to the pandemic that
we'll be talking about we'll be talking
about an anti-vaccine hearing we will be
talking about
lab leak but first let's just kind of
reset where we are
coronavirus cases in the united states
are now
down more than 94 we are now
at the point where we are asking
with so many people refusing to get
vaccinated
how much lower our case is going to go
because this thing is going to keep
floating around
are we getting to about as low a point
in daily cases as we're going to get
anytime soon
because the virus is going to keep
floating around among unvaccinated
populations i think the answer is not
quite yet
i think we'll still see a decline but
we'll know within two to three weeks but
we are down more than 94 percent
uh from the case peak in roughly
mid-january now in terms of u.s
coronavirus deaths
we are now down more than 88 in daily
deaths
still 400 people a day are dying in the
united states of coronavirus it's still
a horrible number
but when we talk about getting back to
baseline risk
uh i believe it's around 300 people a
day
over a year that during the average flu
season
die in the united states so we're
getting very close
to that baseline level of risk that we
see
equivalent to the flu uh 400
is still high but it is the lowest it's
been during the the entire pandemic
you've got to go back to march of 2020
to find
death numbers this low in the united
united states
now there are many people saying and if
you emailed me you know david is this
actually because of the vaccines or is
this just because of the seasonality
because if you look at cases and deaths
last summer
they were just as low and that's not at
all true
so the first question is are the
premises right and they are not we are
now at 14 000 cases per day
and declining the lowest point last
summer was 22
000 cases per day and they went all the
way up to 70
000 cases per day so it's not even close
it's not true
that cases were this low last summer
now looking globally cases are now down
about 50
last week we were down 40 from the
global peak
now we're down 50 from the global peak
remember that the global peak was about
830
000 cases per day an insane number so
this is already
major progress although there's still a
long way to go and many parts of the
world are
completely or almost completely
unvaccinated and then globally
deaths which as we now know
lag cases by several weeks global deaths
are down
about 34 from their peak
we still have nearly 10 000 people a day
dying of covid
globally much of that is the
unvaccinated population
but we are down from more than 14 000
deaths a day
so everything's moving in the right
direction never as quickly as we would
like
but fortunately vaccinations in the
united states are starting to tick back
up again
after months-long decline so we started
seeing this
in mid-april daily vaccinations peaked
at roughly 3.3 million a day that was a
very good number we were hoping to get
the 3.5 or even 4 million a day but then
vaccinations started to decline and
decline
and decline all the way down to under 1
million vaccinations per day over the
last week
we were down last week we had a one week
average
of 930 vaccinations per day
in a country of 331 million people it's
terrible
it's pathetic it's horrifying and we'll
talk about the anti-vac stuff in a bit
we are now starting to see a slight
uptick once again
back up to about 1.1 million
vaccine doses per day so there will
hopefully now
be the more reluctant people
who will start to realize maybe my
school is going to require the vaccine
maybe my employer is going to require
the vaccine maybe the vaccine will be
required
to go on a trip to the country that i
want to go
and visit maybe you need a vaccine to
sit in the vaccinated full capacity
section
of your local sports stadium and maybe
that will encourage people to go
and get themselves vaccinated whatever
the case one million vaccine doses a day
just isn't good
when we still have so many tens of
millions upon tens of millions of people
who could go and get a vaccine these are
widely available there are countries
desperate to get vaccines
we have so many and yet one-fifth of the
population by last count
just isn't interested now one thing that
does seem like it will convince people
maybe will be full fda approval of the
vaccines
the the uh the unvaccinated population
one third of that population says
i will be going to get a vaccine once
the fda
fully approves the vaccines remember
right now they're
approved under an emergency use
authorization not full approval
so i would love to believe that as soon
as that approval comes
one third of the vaccine hesitant folks
will go and get vaccinated
i can't say i'm convinced i think it's
something that many
of them are saying right now and then
once that full approval
comes down they're going to come up with
something else now i also just disagree
with the premise of saying i'm going to
wait for the full approval before going
and getting vaccinated catching covet in
the meantime
while you wait for that full approval is
likely
statistically to be way worse than
the side effects you might have from the
vaccine before it's fully approved and
remember one once it's fully approved
then it will be
the side effects aren't going to change
the efficacy is not going to change
uh but with the approval coming it would
be great to take
any of that anti-vaxx group vaccine
hesitant group
off the table and get them vaccinated if
they're if they're genuinely waiting for
full approval
and they're really going to go and get
vaccinated at that time uh great
i look forward to them doing that i've
often had trouble falling asleep when
i'm staring at my computer or phone
screen
late into the night and that's partially
because blue light
from screens suppresses the sleep
hormone melatonin
and blue light can generally cause
things like eye strain or even headaches
but it has not been an issue for me
since i was sent a pair of
blue blocks glasses which block out blue
light
unlike all of the low-quality
mass-produced blue light glasses out
there blue blocks
are actually evidence-backed made under
optics laboratory conditions
these are the blue light glasses you can
trust and they have something for
everybody lenses for daytime lenses you
wear before bed
they have a prescription version
non-prescription readers
over 40 different frames to choose from
these are the ones i picked out i never
have problems with it anymore
it's great go to blue blueblocks.com
pacman or click the link below and
you'll get 20
off when you use the coupon code pacman
20
and there's free shipping worldwide on
orders over 115 dollars